think that this That 70s Show callback
was scripted you can shove it Netflix is
that 90s show serves as the perfect
sequel series to the Beloved That 70s
Show while that series ended on New
Year's Eve 1979 that 90s show picks up
15 years later Eric and Donna are
married and they have a 15 year old
daughter Leia while they've moved to
Chicago they return to Point Place for
the 4th of July where Leia meets some of
the new local kids and wants to spend
the summer having Adventures it captures
the heart of family and carefree spirit
that encapsulated much of That 70s Show
while setting the stage for future
Seasons however the show also paid
tribute to what had come before
especially when it came to including the
original cast members while there was a
good reason Hyde didn't come back the
rest of the main gang all make cameos
and of course red and kitty are there
for every episode but the show managed
to bring elements of the past more than
just having the original cast come back
there were other subtle shout outs and
nods including one particularly sweet
moment between Eric and Donna Aaron Eric
and Donna were the emotional core of
That 70s Show so it was great to see the
two of them finally make it work in that
90s show while the two only pop up
together in a single episode they make
the most of it and we are treated to one
of the sweetest moments in the entire
season when the couple appears on the
hood of a car it's reminiscent of the
pilot of That 70s Show when the two of
them got back from a concert and just
hung out but that wasn't the only
callback within that particular scene
the creators of that 90s show did an
interview with BuzzFeed where they broke
down all of the various minutia of the
new series and Terry Turner revealed
that in the first episode of that 90s
show the little push the couple gives
each other was completely unscripted he
explained Topher and Laura did it
without even thinking it was fun to
watch people come back from the original
cast and drop so easily into the
characters they just put them on like an
old shirt
nah feels forced the moment really
cements how much the two of them have
been through and how much they still
love one another hopefully if Netflix
picks up that 90s show for more seasons
we'll be able to see more of Eric and
Donna naturally that wasn't the only
callback to the original show across the
10 episodes of its first season that 90s
show managed to pay tribute to That 70s
Show many times some of these shout outs
were fairly obvious like when Kelso
first enters the foreman residence
slightly deeper cut for instance the
opening scene of that 90s show has Kitty
in the kitchen making food she's dancing
and singing along to groove is in the
Heart by Delight in the pilot episode of
That 70s Show she is once again in the
kitchen making food dancing and singing
Love Will Keep Us Together by Captain
antoniel but the pilot of that 90s show
takes even more from its parent Series
in the episode the kids stumble upon a
keg but they need to go to a liquor
store to get a tap to use it it's
immediately reminiscent of an early
episode of That 70s Show when Eric and
his friends found themselves in a
similar predicament while these specific
characters in the two shows might not be
the same it just goes to show that when
it comes to Point Place some things
never change
foreign
[Music]